labor when the New Deal was enacted gave
up a lot of control over its own health
insurance and pensions and became really
the consumer of these these items and
the New Deal which I would have
supported and supported and a big fan of
the New Deal just want to have another
new deal but what happened is labor
developed a whole expertise of being
able to set up health plans and
insurance and housing and you know labor
was really entrepreneurial because it
had to take care of its own members and
one of the biggest problems is that the
UAW negotiated for health and pension
and then it was delivered by you know
big insurance carriers and the big
problem is this runaway costs and the
inflation associated with health care
and so that's one of the reasons why it
became very expensive if let's say there
were clinics and they were run by nurse
practitioners and physicians assistants
and there was like real attention to
wellness and attention to diabetes and
obesity and high blood pressure and we
really managed it we did these
innovative things if a union has the
membership and has the control over its
own business of the insurance it's going
to see to it that the members get those
things because their economic interests
are aligned when you're just negotiating
for it you don't really care all you
know is that this is how much that piece
of insurance or that pension costs and
you just want to make sure that the
workers not bearing that cost and I
don't I'd say that the problem is that
labor was one piece of a whole system
that wasn't managing those costs but it
was never asked to manage those costs in
the collective bargaining system
you know i would say that in the 80s was
really you know if you remember back to
nineteen eighty or 81 or 82 with packed
oh you know ronald reagan came in and
made sure that that was you know one of
the top items on his agenda and when you
look at what happened to labor you know
that there definitely is a connection
between that and the way our labor laws
work you know if you are an employer in
the middle of an organizing Drive it
makes very good sense to fire the the
key workers because there's no penalty
the penalty means that the worker
eventually might get their job back and
you just have to quote make them whole
and what make them whole means is just
pay them back with inflation there's not
any real damage to it whereas if you're
an employer and you don't pay wages the
department of labor will come after you
and there are potentially criminal
charges attached to that so clearly
we've had a government that has not
necessarily wanted to see the rise of
unions in a way that lets say FDR
certainly did
well you know it's funny because in
France they the French labor movement
actually has about the same low rates of
unionization that we have it's just
everybody's out on the street and you
know another interesting kind of
factoids is that unions tend to grow
during prosperity not during times like
these because people are scared of their
jobs the only exception was you know the
20s and the 30s so I think it's more
like it needs to be more tactical and
you know in this this is really
relatively new we really haven't seen it
and I do think that people are ready and
I think they're ready for for its not to
sound ridiculous but they're ready for
change mostly because the alternative is
is worse